وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه اعربت عن قلاقها
البالغ اذا القذف التركي الاخير على
العراق وايضا شمال سوريا اشارت الى ان تلك
الاعمال تزعزع استقرار المنطقه الخارجيه
الامريكيه حتى على الوقف الفوري للتصعيد
شمال سوريا وايضا اشارت في الوقت ذاته الى
ان الاعمال العسكريه شمال سوريا تهدد مهمه
التصدي لتنظيم داعش فيما اكدت وزاره
الدفاع الامريكيه البنتاجون اكدت طبعا ان
الضربات الجويه التي تنفذها تركيا ونفذتها
في الاونه الاخيره في شمال سوريا تمثل
تهديد مباشر لسلامه العسكريين الامريكيين
البنتاجون طلبه بوقف صوري لاعمال التصعيد
مشيرا الى تفهم واشنطن لما وسطها بالمخاوف
الامنيه المشروعه لتركيا طبعا هذا التفاهم
الامريكي للمخاوف التركيه راى فيه البعض
نوع من التراخي في دعم ما قصد والتي قامت
بدورها بوقف التنسيق مع التحالف الدولي
والقتال ضد داعش بحسب حق قائد قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه مظلوم عبد عبدي قال ان
الولايات المتحده لديها واجب اخلاقي
لثني الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان عن
اصدار امر بشان هجوم بريه على شمال شرق
سوريا اضعف انه بالرغم من انه تلقى
معلومات استخباريه تؤكد طلب تركيا من
وكلاءها المحليين لاستعداد للهجوم البري
الا ان الاداره الامريكيه اداره الرئيس
بيدن لا زالت قادره على اقناع اردوغان
بالتراجع طبعا هذا بالنسبه للموقف
الامريكي همم بالنسبه لروسيا فقد اكد
المبعوث الروسي الخاص الى سوريا
انطباع بان تركيا ستمتنع عن شنه هجوم بري
على سوريا وقال لي وكاله نفوستي ان روسيا
تقوم من خلال وزاره الدفاع باقناع جميع
الاطراف ضروره ضبط النفس والابتعاد عن
التصعيد اشار ايضا الى ان موسكو مستعده
لتنظيم لقاء بين الرئيسين السوري طبعا هنا
نتحدث بشار الاسد والتركي رجب طيب اردوغان
طبعا هذا بالنسبه للجانب السوري والتطورات
هناك اما العراق فقد اعلن عزمه اعاده نشر
قواته على حدوده مع كل من ايران وايضا من
تركيا هذا القرار ياتي بعد ايضا القصف
المتكرر الذي نفذته طهران وانقره وطلع عدد
من المناطق في اقليم كردستان العراق
الحكومه العراقيه قالت في بيان صدره بعد
اجتماع للمجلس الوزاري للامن الوطني قالت
انها قررت وضع خطه لاعاده نشر القوات
الحدود العراقيه لمسك الخط الصفري على طول
الحدود مع ايران وتركيا اوضح البيان ان
هذه الخطه ستضع بالتنسيق مع حكومه اقليم
كردستان العراق ووزاره البشمركه